muchas mujeres afganas estas imágenes
son una pesadilla hecha realidad el
rápido avance del grupo talibán hasta
que sus vidas corran peligro
ya estamos escuchando y viendo informes
de niñas y adolescentes que son
arrebatadas de sus familias y entregadas
a los insurgentes para ser obligadas a
casarse ya está ocurriendo las escuelas
están cerrando
y si los insurgentes toman kabul las
consecuencias para las mujeres serán
catastróficas cuando los islamistas
gobernaban el país entre 1996 y 2001
impusieron una versión estricta de la
ley islámica las mujeres tenían
prohibido salir sin un hombre a su lado
trabajar o recibir educación quienes
eran acusadas de delitos como el
adulterio eran azotada si a pedradas
hasta la muerte en las zonas controladas
por el grupo talibán en la actualidad
estas normas ya están entrando en vigor
busco la trabajo de colofón nuevas zonas
data no en todas las mujeres afganas
tienen problemas psicológicos no sólo
aquí las mujeres no salen mucho y no se
ven mucho más que
muchas están optando por huir casi
250.000 afganos han huido de sus hogares
desde finales de mayo el 80% de ellos
son mujeres y niños gispert y tulio
rifas resulta especialmente horripilante
y desgarrador ver cómo se arrebatan a
las niñas y mujeres rascan a los
derechos que tanto les ha costado
conseguir rondan en el primer semestre
de 2001 las mujeres y los niños
representaron casi la mitad de las
víctimas civiles de la guerra afgana